[Music]
so here we are with a number for game of
the year Dishonored 2 from Arkane
Studios obviously the sequel to the 2012
game which a lot of us love but dishonor
to kind of took a lot of things that
made that game great and just flush them
out to the tenth degree your rightful
Empress has returned all hail the
Empress delight first of her name arrest
Emily called winning her father for the
crown killer murders what
Jake you played a lot of this don't
really have to play dishonor to one way
or the other in fact it almost
encourages replayability can you tell me
about that that's one of the most
beautiful things about this game is that
you can either play stealth you can play
assault and a lot of games try to do
that now but I feel like this game
really embodies it you can play assault
you can play stealth you can play
somewhere in between and then from there
you can get different powers that cater
to each of these different play styles
and if you're a hardcore and you don't
want to use powers you can just go
completely powerless and try out that
run this is the moment that changed him
now it's your turn Emily yeah it leaves
a lot of room for creativity we think
the powers are unlocking the gadgets
your kind of experimenting with the
world itself you're exploring the whole
time you know it's all about
experimentation you can quick little
quick save vice versa to kind of
encourage you to really try new things
scotney tell me about that creativity of
fosters yeah so it really does improve
over the first game in giving people
more option so regardless of if you
choose to play stealth or action you're
going to have satisfying mechanics to
back up your play style like you can
perform non-lethal drop attack now you
like dive off a roof and chunk someone
out before they hit the ground which is
kind of Awesome is the fact that the
studio has thought of all these
different ways to accommodate whatever
it is you want to do and giving you this
just completely rich and diverse set of
tools to play with and find different
ways and combinations to you know
utilize them in in concert with one
another is really part of just this
mechanical richness that makes dishonor
to such a great game
you and me yeah and all this is
unfolding throughout this really unique
world right the space around wailing
almost steampunk kind of like the
discovery of these new inventions they
have like almost the Leonardo da Vinci
characters kind of like fleshed out this
world as you're playing throughout
karnatka where the game is set it kind
of really flesh itself out well the more
time you spend with it with these little
notes these audio logs yeah and to be
honest the story kind of faded into the
periphery for me but the thing that I
took away most was this world and how
expertly designed all of these levels
are and there's almost a story with
everything you find like every little
object seems to have some sort of
purpose like wailing for instance you
see a dead whale and that plays a huge
role into the game the whale oil is what
kind of keeps this society running and
then you can also take that to the
degree with with the citizens you can
follow them around they have their own
schedule they have their own sort of
lifestyle which you can kind of take a
peek at pans out begging and whining
tell the truth for once you lying coward
what did you make on this promise shape
one yeah when you're learning that kind
of the routes these guards or the you
know the everyday routines that these
people talk about and talking to their
spouse or their friend or just someone
that's passing them by you kind of get
the sense of this world has existed long
before you set foot in it and then
that's exemplified by the level design
these sandbox is like finding these
ruins of these bone charms make your
character better I spent so long on each
mission just scouring every inch of it
using the heart to find anything what
you luda do with the heart is exactly
right and that's part of sort of the
frustration but ultimately the beauty of
the way this game is bills and so you
have you have this heart with you at all
times and it will tell you when you are
near a certain type of object like a
rune or a barn charm these things that
allow you to upgrade your character and
that can be incredibly frustrating to
know that you're like four meters away
from a rune but it's on the other side
of a wall and how do you get there and
yeah it's some of them will absolutely
drive you insane but a lot of them are
really cleverly hidden and are almost
kind of a puzzle in and of themselves
and it forces you to think about the
world around you in a different way and
kind of appreciate the nuance and
thought that went into building these
environments and and ultimately the
world
self yeah dishonor to is a master class
in so many different areas level design
like its stories and the most standout
thing but the way it builds its world
how it encourages experimentation on
fosters creativity Scott you had said I
was like that choice and consequence
kind of first-person narrative adventure
and I think Arkane Studios really nailed
it with a sequel and stand out from the
other games this year you have to be
pretty special and I think dishonor to
really does that and that's why it's our
number for game of 2016
you
[Music]